sima alvey takes health care decisions
for her daughter nuseba
delicately an open heart surgery and a
severe learning disability
means nusaber has largely been shielding
since march
very nice the kovid vaccine signals hope
but simon wants to see evidence that
it's safe for children
what are the long-term effects on a
child like sabre who's already got
medical problems
you know she's not a normal child so
that just does worry me a little bit as
well in the back of my eye but i have to
weigh up the risks
[Music]
clinical trials are set to begin to test
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine in
children
the trial is the first to assess the
oxford vaccines efficacy in children
aged 6 to 17.
other trials have already begun but
they're for teens
aged 16 and 17. across
england there are more than 55 000
children under 18 classified as
extremely vulnerable people who have
been shielding
as part of this trial researchers will
look at the immune responses of 300
children
we need to take blood tests over a
period of time to look at the immune
responses
and see how long the immune responses
last in all the children who will be
taking part we hope to take up to
five blood tests over 12 months so it
will take us about 12 months before we
get all of our data unable to analyze it
most children are relatively unaffected
by coronavirus and few are likely to
have severe illness from it
but their role in spreading the virus
remains unclear
dr ravi jayaram says it could be
compared with other vaccines currently
used to control
transmission we could compare this to
the vaccination of children for rubella
or german measles
we know that german measles in children
causes a relatively mild illness
but we know that pregnant mums who catch
rubella can develop major abnormalities
in their babies so we vaccinate children
to protect pregnant mums and also down
the line it reduces the amount of virus
around in the communities
the pandemic has had a profound negative
impact on children
and young people like nusaber but the
new trials offer a chance to answer
important questions about controlling
the virus in younger age groups
sadia chaudhary sky news